what is screenwriter homework and can
you give me an assignment
so your homework can give you an
assignment all right so the homework is
doing the work
first off uh but let's go with a
specific assignment for you
um you want to come up with an idea for
a story
um but you don't really know where to
start so one good place to start that i
have in my book
is the comp game so
for those who don't know what a comp is
a comp is this meets that
you know so like a movie is harry meets
sally
meets airbud what is that movie gonna be
so there's your assignment you come up
with and this is a um
since my fiance's sitting here i'll tell
this story okay uh
so a script i have out uh that i'm
passing on is called run
uh it is a story about a detective who
is being forced to
run non-stop uh in order to save her
daughter from a killer
um placed in several contests
at this point um i've been semi-finalist
uh
in in like three of them and
quarterfinalists another two um and it's
a script that like a lot of people seem
to like um
where did that story come from okay so
we were playing the comp game one day
driving to a networking event stuck in
traffic
so we were playing a camp game coming up
with i was coming with
bizarre things she was kind of bizarre
things i think at one point i told her
she needed to do
i might have actually said airbud meets
something else so she gave me okay
saw meets speed okay
so i'm like okay so speed is you know
the dude in the
bus that can't slow down or it's going
to blow up
saw is this killer guy who has these
people and making them do obstacles to
save their own lives
so i mesh them together i now have a
woman who can't stop running or her
daughter will die and she has to
along with running has to do these
various like
uh feats that he makes her do and stuff
like oh she has to run
to this point in this amount of time and
go if you don't then your daughter's
friend who i also have kidnapped is
gonna die
so i'm combining those two things so
there's your homework
let's give you a like a couple of uh
comps or whatever
to come up with so okay so
how about 16 candles meets home alone
okay 16 candles in the home alone so
we're going to take those two movies
we're merging together
16 candles you got a story about a girl
who it's her birthday and everyone seems
to have forgotten that it's her birthday
uh home alone is a guy who his parents
go on vacation and leave him there
awesome all right so
we got kids home alone it's his birthday
all right so we've got
kids birthday uh he wakes up nobody
remembers his birthday he goes off
he comes home to a house that is full of
stuff for a surprise party but everyone
else is gone they set up and they left
him alone
so while he's at the surprise party
waiting around his own party
uh some people try to break into his
house luckily he's got things
already around now that he can use to
defend himself he has a banner that he
turns into a giant slingshot to shoot
the
bad guys across the street uh they come
in oh look here's birthday cake with
with uh trick candles on it so he lights
the trick candles now he's got
roman candle torch that he can use as
defense and shoot it off like a big
firework of people
uh and then the parents once he's
defeated the bad guys they come home
everybody comes home forgetting that
they set up for this birthday party
don't know why there's all this mess
here until the mom finds the uh
the banner at the end and then oh by the
way your birthday present
happens to be something he destroyed
while trying to do it
idea outside my head it probably sucks i
know it sucks but
there that's kind of what the comp game
is you come up with things
they may not be good they may be amazing
it's kind of a thing of trying to figure
out how to
meld the two things together because
there is i'm a firm believer that there
are no more original stories
left to tell because we've been telling
stories since the dawn of time
the trick is to find new ways into the
stories
and the reason i have the comp game is a
fantastic way of doing that is taking
two stories that already exist and
finding where they meet in the middle
was it the venn diagram where they've
got the circles and things over here so
finding those things is a great way to
to
create your own story by melding other
stories already existing i'm just gonna
be don't be super
obvious about it like i just was with
this 16 candlestone alone
um like i said with the run i i knew it
had to be something that couldn't stop
moving from speed and there had to be a
serial killer
with obstacles like saw and so i created
a whole new character that went into
their
uh and how to mesh them together like
she's no longer on a bus now she's
running you know so find
the the original idea in them um
another thing you can do is coming up
finding
a movie you like but that had a [ __ ]
ending
can i say [ __ ] i'm sorry i still have a
crappy ending
um and uh tweak it to okay
how would you have ended this story can
you now write a story that ends that
way and has a different beginning you
know so so
you can always borrow from other things
like um
even in people borrowing even even uh
william shakespeare was borrowing people
you know
romeo and juliet was not an original
thing he stole romeo and juliet from
like a greek mythology thing and then
just
made his own tweaks to it you know so we
can make our own tweaks to everything so
your homework
is to find a story that already exists
find a way to spin it and make it a
completely new original story
okay argo and sleeping with the enemy
oh crap can we just cut i don't want to
do that anymore oh jeez
we could end it there okay sorry i just
wanted to
throw out that one okay now we're not
thinking about it though
i'm thinking about that that was just
for fun no we won't do that
[Laughter]
so somebody got kidnapped
and it was it turns out that it was his
lover
but in order in order to save his lover
he has to make a movie that involves his
lover
this actually sounds like a good one
okay
this is a fun game so it should be a
party game yeah you should i can see
michael's crafts
there is a similar party game oh we have
it what's it called
uh pitch storm is similar that one it
doesn't do it doesn't do quite the same
thing it doesn't take movies and make
you combine them a pitch storm
is uh it's a card game where on each on
the cards they have
different elements like a certain type
of character and a certain scenario
and you have to come up with the story
that uses that and you're
pitching it and then um it has kind of
like a an
apples-to-apples component so there's a
judge and the judge is actually throwing
out
things too they're actually being the
executive you know and so while you're
telling the story
at any point they can stop you like oh
but what if and then they have an
executive card that has like some random
thing that they throw in there some note
that they're like oh what if
you know you're so i'm telling my story
of run you know the woman who's
let's say my thing was a detective and
and running and so like i'm telling the
story okay so she's running
and the detect or the bad guy calls her
and tells her she has to get to this
certain point
and he goes oh let me stop you what if
suddenly
aliens drop down so you know it's a
bizarre little game like that it's a
similar concept
but not quite the same i i've thought
about trying to do that but i'm not sure
i'm not sure what the legality would be
of
as far as the copywriting stuff you know
putting out a game where i'm where it's
like a bunch of movie things that you
haven't come out you can do it on your
own so
you know it's not really something like
phil needs to have it but i'm like
it could be like a extra thing to go
with the book i guess
you